se ríen listo les dice a las chicas ahí
cosas de reportero y un kawar se involucra
metapolítica en la misión política
del ex suboficial dice que el final va
en granaria clara que nova cree ste
tercera fiesta la fiesta que ya varios
analista 15 o para llamar a la fiesta
patriota en un hot dog días nada
entonó esta versión de la creación
de un tercero me iba precisamente porque
airear la puerta abierta lo democratas da lo
pide crear el probador practico seriv
de vía el voto republicano de los propios que al
contrario a unirse a los portales serios y la
partido republicano que este momento
estilo io precisamente en el software esa
clientes mientras que los republicanos que ya
no se aleja pero silas la politica
sentencia la línea que los está tirando
frente masaryk almas nacionalista en
partido Republicano
los hackers que mantienen a los phillies en
agente as est ed cruz comuna marco
rubio como lindsey graham sena loris
queja afecta y precisamente y en
es chicchiere evitar al presidente
roth superpone cara en la selección
legislacion del smilab enti sale en tv
que lo que es solo ya basta
un pequeño kai solo democratas estos
primer cuartel de hermes y el legislativo
soy republicano en el mar donado
control de la cámara waka y el senado d
alema muéveme haz esto
posibilidad abierta de delegar a
presente y en 2024 en el resto de los mares
esto obviamente 11 o pasión en el
publico separa un lob laudiero de
angri tawiah smessi tablero de ajedrez al
presidente un canto que su campaña
tambien
salgo lo que provoca que estos no
presenta y el ex presidente este
campaña para presidente y nuestro #4
años este ambiente ya en barrios y
libre y democrático podría sufrir
Pascua de Resurrección
el decreto presidencial culo y piedra
algodon entrada otros cristo e
probablemente otro agujero de tema central
en críticas al presidente Biden y
específicamente en usado subiendo
Migrantes centroamericanos que contiene
declaraciones enel y en el núcleo de
partido de la oposición como un caramelo
thorne el 24 estas escribiendo farmhouse pero si
este ep no caracas y este simplicio
vico donald trump que construyó
ya quien nada nos millas si la frontera
que distorsionó focas millas hasta el final
estímulo y la frontera que siguen e
lauria su esposa fech tv.it biden ha
ahora parece la construccion del para muro
tambien y tema y volver a crecer solo
70 de asilo en mexico para tambien y el
tema las nuevas estrellas mas il sede del migrante
familia calena que vivia en el pueblo
escalera eros que estaba limpiando para entrar
incluso si la gestión de la nuez juntos
Borbera de rábano pájaro carpintero puede ser con
entra tu sabes critico la pela de la
política si el sordo y el ejecutivo tuvieran
hayden diciendo que el la esta intrigando
pais allo sci migrantes diciendo que son
los migrantes que no saben es que entre en
criticándolo diciendo que su hormona
campo que sobre el ladrillo perforante el
tiene valor sexual niega estatus
en noticias para tener acceso a las características
del mismo un entendimiento es que la disminución de la
casos recurrentes de mucho tiempo hasta tres
minutos y de su discurso para criticar
volver a lucy migrantes municipio es
fundamental del movimiento de las trompetas el
mi papel
mas que generó el preguntar si
generando jong y son sala de audiencias del
migrantes que la corren a la frontera de
contra papeletas gastadas biden las aulas la
puerta encuentra la tienda y giotti sombra
para entre el ministro de trafico
personas y la frontera en tres doctor es
estado en el uschi preguntó en tono de
ser argumento suficiente para que se
crear con el legislativo si en 2020 el
nosotros presentadores en 2004